how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we're talking about yet
another topic from phase four that we
probably would have had already if it
wasn't for the virus but it looks like
there's nothing but good news ahead for
phase four and today we're going to be
talking about the eternal specifically
the Eternals trailer that has been
rumored to be coming out soon for a very
long time now unfortunately the movie
has been pushed back to February of 2021
luckily it hasn't been pushed back that
long we only have about seven months
left until the movie comes out which
means we could get the trailer at any
point now Marvel does have a tendency to
tease their projects in advance and
today we have a report that something
for the Eternals is cooking up and could
be released very soon so we'll break all
of this down in this video but if you're
new be sure to subscribe to stay up to
date on all things relating to the MCU
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a Thanos
with the Infinity Gauntlet Funko pop I'm
picking a winner on Monday all you got
to do to enter subscribe like the video
and leave a comment about the video down
below now I think out of all the
trailers that are coming for phase 4
I've been asked about the Eternals
trailer the most it's a very unique and
interesting project for Marvel and they
themselves have expressed that and not
too many people know too much about the
Eternals unless you're a pretty avid
comic reader so people are really
looking forward to getting their first
look at the Eternals to see what this
movie exactly is going to be about and
to see how the characters are portrayed
well it looks like we might not have to
wait that much longer today we have a
report from twitter user amit chat hari
now this account previously had posted
reports about the black widow teaser
trailer which ended up being true amit
is apparently a graphics designer and
visual effects artist at arena animation
so he apparently has some connections
but again he was right about some things
when they came to Black Widow and today
he has said heard that Disney and Marvel
are working on something regarding
eternals and it might come soon heard it
from the same source he told me about
the black widow teaser trailer arrival
note that the source didn't confirm
whether it'll be a trailer or anything
else so according to this account
something for the Eternals is coming
soon now there have been plenty of
rumors going around for the past a month
or so saying that the Eternals trailer
is coming and while all the rumors were
around a lot of people said that it's
probably coming at San Diego comic-con
at home however we know that Marvel
Studios really is an attending of San
Diego comic-con at home and this came as
a pretty big shock although SDCC is not
going to be nearly the same this year as
it has been over the past 50 years it
was still a pretty big shock because
SDCC is where Marvel Studios reveals
their biggest reveals of the year for
example last year they revealed the
entire phase for slate of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and even a little bit
more past phase 4 they mentioned blade
the Fantastic Four Captain Marvel -
black panther - and mutants so needless
to say it's a pretty big deal and it's a
big deal that they're sitting this one
out but it doesn't mean that they're not
going to be releasing thanks pretty soon
we're actually pretty long overdue for
teaser trailers for the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier the one division series
and the Eternals trailer and up to this
point we've had several reports that
teaser trailers are coming for all of
these projects so now it seems like
Marvel Studios might be hosting their
own event they've done this in the past
before and DC is sitting San Diego
comic-con at home out as well to host
their own DC fan dome event at this
event they're going to be releasing new
material they're going to be talking
about upcoming projects and this is
something that Marvel Studios can do as
well and actually widely believe that
they will do this and they will talk
about their new projects and release new
material now since the Eternals trailer
was expected to come at SDCC at home if
Marvel Studios does host their own event
this is probably where we can expect to
see the very first trailer for the
Eternals and if this event does happen
it's going to happen relatively soon
which means we could be getting the
Eternals teaser trailer pretty soon but
even if they don't do this event they
could just simply release the teaser
trailer for Eternals they could do that
at any point now and Marvel has been
known to do that they just simply
released teaser trailers on certain
dates they did that with the Black Widow
trailer and then not to mention d23
isn't too far away either so there are
plenty of opportunities for us to get
Marvel's eternals trailer at any point
now so let me know how excited you are
to get a first look at the Marvel's
eternals trailer whenever it comes
hopefully very soon don't forget to like
this video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all things relating to the
Eternals and everything relating to the
MCU as well for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll fall
off